[Musica]
ciao ci siete anche voi è appena andato
via lo slimer ma ha lasciato un
biglietto
cosa c'è scritto riuscirete a trovare la
chiave per scappare mi sa proprio che
dobbiamo iniziare a seguono europa
challenge interattiva se mi vedete un po
diversa e perché ho tagliati tinge i
capelli
che ne pensate come quest'anno credetemi
nei commenti se vi piacciono comunque
questo non video interattivo
questa volta bravo scappare dallo slimer
dobbiamo recuperare la chiave per uscire
dalla costa se non avete ancora
partecipato a nessun video interattivo
mi spiego velocissimamente come funziona
durante il video ci saranno delle gatte
lines musicale poi potrete scegliere una
delle cartelline per procedere con la
storia quindi deciderete voi cosa dovrò
fare in questo video
se sceglierete le caselline giuste
potrete vincere il gioco se sceglierete
quelle sbagliate e perderete potrete
ricominciare daccapo il gioco per
riprovare un'altra volta
l'obiettivo è trovare la chiave è
scappare prima che ci mangelo slimer
questo che mangia qualsiasi cosa
unica regola nessuna spoiler nei
commenti mi raccomando non scrivete la
soluzione nei commenti altrimenti che
gusto c'è per gli altri giocatori
se questo video resine se il 40 mila mi
piace sisters anche l'ex gay rum live
quindi lasciate un bel mi piace prendete
i pop corn e iniziamo subito a giocare
ma prima di iniziare dobbiamo indossare
la nostra tuta da ghostbusters
acchiappafantasmi così sarò più pronto
ad affrontare lo slimer pronti 32 ora è
così colà siamo prontissimi per
affrontare
anche il mio zainetto ma non ho nessuna
arma per affrontare lo slimer quindi
iniziamo subito le nostre prime scelte
come affrontiamolo strymer siamo rumer
pure siccome gli piace mangiare a segno
15 c ne prendiamo qualcosa da mangiare
scegli una delle due caselline
[Musica]